this picture is from my MetroCard when I
spent a year abroad in Paris in college
in the mid-90s my friend says I look
like a French anarchist but this is
still what I see when I look in the
mirror in the morning then a month of
living in Paris I'd lost 15 pounds and I
was in the best shape of my life
because I was eating fresh food and I
was walking wherever I went having grown
up in suburban Atlanta a region built
largely by highways and automobiles and
with a reputation as a poster child for
sprawl Paris fundamentally changed the
way that I understood the construction
of the world around me and I got
obsessed with the role of infrastructure
that it's not just the way to move
people from point A to point B it's not
just a way to convey water or sewer
image energy but it's the foundation for
our economy it's the foundation for our
social life and for our culture and it
really matters to the way that we live
when I came home it was instantly
frustrated stuck in traffic as I was
crossed the top end of our perimeter
highway not only was I not moving a
muscle I had no social interaction with
the hundreds of thousands of people that
were hurtling past me like me with her
eyes face forward and their music
blaring I wondered if this was an
inevitable outcome or could we do
something about it was it possible to
transform this condition in Atlanta into
the kind of place that I wanted to live
in I went back to grad school and
architecture and City Planning developed
those interests in infrastructure and in
1999 came up with an idea for my thesis
project the adaptation of an obsolete
loop of old railroads circling downtown
as a new infrastructure for urban
revitalization it was just an idea I
never thought that we would actually
build it but I went to work at an
architecture firm and eventually talked
to my co-workers about it and they loved
the idea and as we started talking to
more people about it more people wanted
to hear about it in the summer of 2001
we connected with Cathy wood he was soon
elected city council president and we
built a citywide vision around this idea
the Atlanta BeltLine as a 22 mile loop
of transit and trails and transformation
I was doing two and three meetings a
week for two and a half years and so was
Cathy and her staff and a handful of
volunteers and together we built this
amazing movement of people and ideas it
included community advocates who weren't
used to fighting against things but
found the Atlanta BeltLine is something
that they could fight for developers who
saw the opportunity to take advantage of
a lot of new growth in the city and
dozens of nonprofit partners who saw
their their mission at least partly
accomplished by this shared vision now
usually these groups of people aren't at
the same table wanting the same outcome
so but there we were and it was kind of
weird but it was really really powerful
the people of Atlanta fell in love with
a vision that was better than what they
saw through their car windshields and
the people of Atlanta made it happen and
I guarantee you we would not be building
it otherwise from the beginning our
coalition was diverse people of all
stripes were part of our story people on
the lower end of the economic spectrum
loved it too they were just afraid that
they were going to be able to be there
when it got built that they'd be priced
out and we've all heard that kind of
story before right but we promised that
the Atlanta BeltLine would be different
and people took ownership of the idea
and they made it better than anything we
ever imagined in the beginning including
significant subsidies for housing a new
parks our Art Arboretum elisa continues
to grow and we put in place the
organizations and agencies that were
required to make it happen and
importantly it is now we're in the early
stages of implementation and it's
working and the first mainline section
of trail was opened in 2012 and it's
already generated over three billion
dollars of private-sector investment but
it's not only changing the physical form
of the city is
changing the way that we think about the
city and what our expectations are for
living there about a month ago I had to
take my kids with me to the grocery
store and they were complaining about it
because they didn't want to get in the
car and they were there saying dad if we
have to go can we at least ride our
bikes and I said of course we can that's
what people in Atlanta do we ride our
bikes to the grocery store now thank you
yeah now they don't know how ridiculous
that is but I do and I also understand
that their expectations for Atlanta are
really powerful this kind of
transformation is exactly like sprawl in
the last century the movement where our
investment in highways and automobiles
fundamentally changed American life that
wasn't some grand conspiracy there were
conspiracies within it of course but it
was a cultural momentum it was millions
of people making millions of decisions
over an extended period of time that
fundamentally changed not only the way
that we build cities but what it changed
our expectations for our lives these
changes were the foundations for urban
sprawl we didn't call it sprawl at that
time we called it the future and it was
and we got all the highways and strip
malls and cul-de-sacs we wanted it was a
radical transformation but it was built
by a cultural momentum so it's important
to not separate the physical
construction of the places we live from
other things that are happening at that
time at that time in the second half of
the last century science was curing
disease and lifting us to the moon and
the sexual revolution was breaking down
barriers and the civil rights movement
began it's marched for the fulfillment
of our nation's promise television
entertainment food travel business
everything was changing and both the
public and private sectors were
colluding to give us the lives that we
wanted the federal highway
administration for example didn't exist
before there were highways think about
it
of course today it's important to
understand and acknowledge that those
benefits accrued to some groups of
people and not to others it was not an
equitable cultural momentum but when we
look today in wonder and discussed maybe
at the metropolis sprawl before us we
wonder if we're stuck are we stuck with
the legacy of that inequity are we stuck
with this dystopian traffic hellscape
are we've stuck with ramp and urban
displacement with environmental
degradation are we stuck with social
isolation or political polarization are
these inevitable and permanent outcomes
or are they the result of our collective
cultural decisions that we've made for
ourselves and if they are can't we
change them what I have learned from our
experience in Atlanta is not an anomaly
similar stories are playing out
everywhere where people are reclaiming
not only old railroads but also degraded
urban waterways and obsolete roadways
reinventing all of the infrastructure in
their lives whether here in New York or
in Houston or Miami Detroit Philadelphia
Seoul Hong Kong Singapore Toronto and
Paris cities big and small all over the
world are reclaiming and reinventing
this infrastructure for themselves
including the mother of all catalysts
infrastructure projects the Los Angeles
River the revitalization effort for
which similarly started as a grassroots
movement has developed into a cultural
momentum and is now in the early stages
of being transformed into some kind of
life-affirming infrastructure again this
one with trails and parks and fishing
and boating and community revitalization
and of course water quality and flood
control it's already improving the lives
of people it's already changing the way
that the rest of us think about Los
Angeles this is more than just
infrastructure we're building new lives
for ourselves it's a movement that
includes local food urban agriculture or
craft beer and the maker
movement tech and design all of these
things early indicators of a really
radical shift in the way that we build
cities we're taking places like this and
transforming them into this and send us
and this is all exciting and good we're
changing the world for the better good
for us and it is awesome I mean that but
our history of sprawl and what from what
we can already see with these catalyst
projects today we know and must remember
that big changes like this don't usually
benefit everyone the market forces
unleashed by this cultural momentum
often include the seemingly unstoppable
an inevitable cycle of rising taxes
prices and rents this is urgent if we
care we have to stand up and speak out
there should be a call to action because
the answer can't be to not improve
communities you know that answer can't
be to not build parks and transit and
grocery stores the answer can't be to
hold communities down just to keep them
affordable but we do have to follow
through with an address the financial
realities that we're facing this is hard
and it won't happen on its own we can do
it and I'm committed to this goal in
Atlanta to sticking up again for people
who made it possible in the plort in the
first place we can't call it a success
without them I certainly can't because
the people that I made commitments to
all those years weren't abstract
populations they're my friends and
neighbors they're people that I love so
even though it started as my graduate
thesis and I'm working hard for 16 years
with thousands of people to help make
this thing come to life I know and
believe that who the Beltline is being
built for is just as important as
whether it's built at all not just in
Atlanta but locally and globally we have
to understand this accountability to the
people whose lives we're changing
because this is us we are the lives
we're talking about
these places aren't inevitable the
places we live aren't inevitable and if
we want something different we just need
to speak up we have to ensure that
change comes on our terms and to do that
we have to participate actively in the
process of shaping change thank you